c'est vrai qu'elle a eu deux enfants
très rapprochés qu'elle a eu ces deux
grossesses et puis qu'après ben
forcément quand on vit de grossesse
comme ça on a besoin de se retrouver un
peu avec son mari se retrouver homme
ils avaient besoin de se retrouver de se
retrouver amoureux et c'est bien je
trouve parce que il préserve leur couple
de langue de bois et sur ma vie j'avais
besoin de ce voyage
#etox du couple ça veut dire quoi
de ce comment dire de se purifier avec
raté elle a le droit de
se purifier avec son mari
si tu viens pour nous sortir des trucs
de presse Nord dit la vérité la vérité
ils sont tout va très bien il y a aucun
problème simplement c'est vrai qui
travaille ensemble ils ont eu un
deuxième enfant cette année donc
forcément tout ce que ça implique